n napoléon est né à bethléem en gagner
s'amuse à 10 ans on est triste on va
chez napoléon et années dans une natte
corse
l'agriculture c'est l'accord jeu pensez
vous il est né un 15 août en plein
embouteillage commissaire broussard tout
comme un bébé ni plus doucement à gober
dit tu es ma fille
l'accouchement fut difficile
en effet il était né à sète le chapeau
sur la pêche au homard dominique wils au
rotary soirée
les années passent naboléon monte sur le
continent il assiste aux grands moments
de l'histoire exemple la révolution
française
mais quelque peu gracieux et sans pilote
qui dura j'étais le roi de france louis
saez et toi elle dame qui tue mais un
sans gêne au 18 heures la royauté
terminé il va prendre la france en main
c'est moi variane l'ubs ont bien plus
tard un jour se promenant dans les
tuileries
il rencontre joséphine et
prod il est mignon ce petit je le ferai
bien investi je m'appelle doudou de
beauharnais pouvoir y tue parce que nos
copines qui s'appelle aussi joséphine se
définit comme joséphine baquet mais les
années passent et les rapports du couple
se dégradent écoute doudou est tout
petit laid oyonnax marque est toujours
là tu rates de guerroyer à droite à
gauche on ne voit jamais à maison les
atteindre maintenant une victoire
m'appelle
moi je veux marcher je sais des bananes
les grandes batailles ce succès marc ago
à austerlitz
le soleil brille aiello il brille aussi
les mots le champ libre et laval rhône
s'il fut l'apogée de l'empiré incroyable
na waie
au cours de ces grandes batailles de
grands maréchaux s'il lui ce maréchal
ney la chaîne mcdonald's pas qu'on lui
en ai marre qu'on ne peut pas prêt à
lâcher vrai avec et si vous faites vous
à chaque fois mais non les mecs et
panamera ya au turbin soldats je suis
content de vous non entre temps il
rencontre m'arrivait les chiens non lech
walesa
tu viens chez les hommes a perdu
d'arnold dans la tasse union d'où naquit
le gland
entre temps la russie l'appel voilà
chasse ouais je suis dans ces bars et
c'est alors qu'après sa retraite en fait
laquelle sam de 60 ans mais non la
retraite de russie
crois tu que nous allons y laisser
beaucoup d'âmes bad est une des races il
passe tout cela remet à gauche c'est bon
pour les municipales pendant la retraite
un soldat raconte arrivages et vous
qu'ils disaient
sans blague moi j'aimais les jeunes lui
ce fut waterloo chef chef effroyable
sont américaines qui puisse partout là
on a la frite mais oui mais je fonte de
la neige alors napoléon sur la fin se
reconvertit et s'installe à sainte
hélène par ici messieurs dames s'ils
veulent être mais la race des napoléon
n'est pas morte
naples et on ne sort pas grandi de cet
intermède merci d'avoir suivi avec nous
cet apéritif du sourire bonsoir à 2 me